we should turn to people in the culture
like this ufc fighter
who i had never heard of before because
i don't really follow the sport but she
is
great and she's much smarter than
any of these of these experts around us
rose namahunas
i don't know she made this point in an
interview that
for her she would rather be dead than
red
i have i have a lot to fight for in this
fight and what she represents
and um you know uh
i was just i was just kind of reminding
myself of you know
all the my background and everywhere
that i come from and my family and
everything like that and
we watched um and i kind of wanted to
educate my
training partner chico camus on uh
the lithuanian struggle and like just
the history of it all and um so we
watched the other dream team just to
kind of get like a
overall sentiment of what we fight for
and um so just the
after watching that it was just a huge
reminder of like yeah it's better
better dead than red you know and i
think um
i don't think it's any coincidence that
whaley is red
you know she's uh that's what she
represents it's nothing personal against
her
but um that's a huge motivating factor
of why i fight and i fight for freedom
so this fighter she goes on it's very
eloquent she i guess this other fighter
that she's referring to is some sort of
pinko
and she says look we have we actually
have different values here
i would rather be dead than red yes that
that's not just
jingoist slogans that americans used to
recite during the cold war that is a
moral truth
i would rather be dead than red
this goes right back to the bible when
christ says do not fear those
who can destroy your body but destroy
but but fear him
who can destroy your body and your soul
in hell
you should you should not only be
worried about your physical safety all
that
that will that will deprive you of your
dignity and you're gonna end up
well i guess we're we're living in a
moment when people are denying human
dignity more broadly
by creating little hybrids in in
laboratories
and by trying to compost humans as we
were discussing yesterday
on the show but i still believe that
humans have dignity
i still think we have a rational soul
we have an intellect and a will and that
we should we're made in the image of god
i believe all of that and so if i were
forced into a
political system that demanded they told
me
you need to embrace a radical
atheist materialist system
called communism or we're going to kill
you it wouldn't take me two seconds
say oh kill me i'm not afraid i'm not
afraid of death i don't want to suffer i
i'm not exactly happy about pain
i don't want to endure that but death
itself
no i'd like to extend my life reasonably
but
you know i'd like to like to live a good
life in accordance with providence
but i know ultimately i'm going to die
and so i don't fear that i want to just
make sure that i'm in a
i'm in a good position when i die i
don't i don't think it's necessarily
wrong for researchers to be trying to
figure out ways to improve human health
but there's a big difference between
researching ways to improve human health
and creating and destroying
human-like creatures semi-human
creatures
for the purpose of living
by their death that is an inversion
of well it's an inversion of
christianity it's an inversion of the
religion that has traditionally built
our civilization
and it's an inversion of all the lines
that we talk about about how we need to
be progressive and selfless and open and
yeah it's all
bunk it's all total bunk stop don't go
anywhere don't i know you were about to
don't before you go you gotta smash
the like button you gotta subscribe
youtube does not wanna be regularly
serving up this kind of content okay not
totally in accord
with the sort of things that they think
so do that you click you click you're
good
i'll see you next time